thank you all I was very much looking
forward to this because I'm hoping that
you can help me to understand how to
better interpret what I'm the material
that I want to share with you you guys I
mean I kind of follow silently a lot of
the online conversations and I'm
learning a lot about how people from
different disciplines approach similar
problems just as a little bit of
background how I got involved in
following the Cuban blogosphere really
came from my own area of study which is
performance because I began to note in
around 2009 and especially in 2010 that
the kind of expressions from of
opponents in Cuba opponents to the
system had taken on a very kind of media
savvy and performative character and
part this was due in large part to the
fact that in 2008 all of the
restrictions were lifted on ownership of
cellphones in Cuba even though they are
very expensive and that has enabled a
lot of people who consider themselves to
be non official artists or independent
journalists or citizen journalists or
activists to use the phones not only to
send text information out but to send
videos and photographs of themselves in
direct confrontation with state
authorities so as a result of that media
presence and that immediacy I argue at
least as part of one of the arguments
that I make in the book that I'm working
on that that suddenly the dissident in
Cuba became in a sense a kind of
performance artist but I thought what I
could do today is to try to give a more
broad presentation to understand why use
in the use of independent media is so
controversial in Cuba but also why it
gets so much attention outside Cuba
because considering the small size of
the Cuban blogosphere and the kind of
independent media culture it gets a
disproportionately high amount of
attention in u.s.
and particularly from the United States
government which has a vested interest
in exploiting the presence of the
independent Cuban bloggers so and that
was is what I think makes this situation
somewhat different from some other
contexts that I have also looked at in
Latin America as the the vested
interests of the US government and the
economic involvement of USAID in
creating this blogosphere but anyway um
so so something justice begin just you
know this is just a picture of a kind of
graffiti that the latest strategy that
is being employed by by a lot of
dissident groups is to try to plaster
their message on on the street since
getting people not most people don't
have access to phones or the internet
and so they've kind of taken up this
stylized form of graffiti that is then
you know reported on by committees for
the defense of revolution and and taken
down or paint it over and this battle
goes on back in back and forth back and
forth but if you just walk by it as a
visitor in Cuba you might think that the
general population is demanding access
free Wi-Fi access so it's important to
understand that this connect Cuba
campaign that it is a part of is funded
by this foundation for human rights in
Cuba which is one of the top recipients
of USAID money so just as I was
preparing this PowerPoint
yes sir Avila who is a dissident
activist and a former computer science
student and open asean verdad agent
published this in the area of the cuba
Kouga which is one of the online daily
blogs that functions like a newspaper or
like an opposition press it's based in
Spain they get money from the National
Endowment for democracy but they don't
sort of come under the radar of critique
from the Cuban government so much
because they are located outside right
but he published this thing about you
know what is public debate
like in Cuba today and basically his
these are his talking points that you
know officially orchestrated public
debate the problem with it is it all
happens in Havana there's no video
documentation so exposure to it remains
limited to those who are present there's
no forum in official Cuban media for any
sort of debate about political issues
only about sports that's the only thing
that's debated in the dailies and on
television the attendance to these
events is by invitation and it is not it
doesn't represent a broad spectrum of
the people in the population you have to
show you're in a way it's a kind of
symbolic thing but you're you're not
really supposed to speak unless you can
demonstrate that you have a certain
professional authority to do so in those
contexts there he talks about the
rhetoric of an or the rhetorical
strategy of being intentionally
obfuscating issues to prevent people
from actually getting to the point but
on the other hand if anybody in the
opposition organizes a similar event
they're harassed by state security and
government officials don't engage in
debate on the issues so that's how he
outlines that's the problem with the
official public sphere as far as he's
concerned now he's a very interesting
figure he was a computer science student
in Havana who in 2008 stood up in a
public meeting with regalo alligoon who
was the head of the National Assembly at
that point and started kind of pointing
the finger at him and asking about
restrict contradictions that he
perceived in government position on
civil rights and press freedoms and so
on and so forth and this was filmed but
with a cell phone and put on YouTube and
became a really famous confrontation he
was also he did not identify himself as
this at the time but at that time he was
working as part for State Security as
part of something called open bid odd or
operation truth where students computer
science students were sent into the
Cuban blogosphere to essentially troll
and harass the independent bloggers and
to try to discredit them so they fill up
their comment
spaces with negative commentary dispute
every single thing they say and
basically just try to make a more
pluralistic debate extremely difficult
if not impossible and in 2000 I think it
was 2011 he came out as a spy inside and
was interviewed by Yoani Sanchez and
told the story of what operation truth
was and has sensed kind of been reborn
as a dissident who says that he wants to
make a new political party and so on and
so forth so he's a very interesting case
ok so here are some key dates this is
all stuff that's fairly recent as you
know you know Cuba has very very low
connectivity in relationship with other
countries in the hemisphere service
begins in 1996 but I remember that
service it was extremely limited and
extremely slow mostly at hotels and
ministries in 2003 after the
imprisonment of 75 journalists Usher's
at independent journalists and activists
that basically shut down what had been a
very small million of kind of
independent journalism print journalism
that had existed before then and so any
kind of dissident publishing activity
begins to move to the Internet at that
point in 2006 you have a major shift in
power with Fidel Castro stepping down
and his brother taking over and claiming
to be the economic reformer in 2007
what explodes is the first major online
into conversation between public
intellectuals about cultural politics
this is known as the bubble in case Luis
Boland was a basically a cult commissar
in the first five years of the 1970s
before there was a Ministry of Culture
in the really kind of height of the
Soviet ization of Cuban cultural
politics when culture was run by the
Communist Party and was responsible for
really basically blacklisting most
famous intellectuals and writers during
that time and then he kind of
disappeared from public life for a long
time and suddenly there there's a
television show on Cuban TV in 2007
where he's brought out and lauded and
this sparks a debate among many an
intergenerational debate in emails
because that most Cubans who have access
to the Internet only have access to a
Cuban base email on but the discussion
quickly got out into the Diaspora about
what it meant to rehabilitate a figure
like that who was so hated right and
what's interesting is it was the first
documented public conversation in which
exiles dissidents opponents and people
who considered themselves still working
within the power structure as members of
the artisan writing we're fighting it
out and fighting out a leg over a legacy
from the 70s that for some people is a
convenient way of saying that's when the
repression existed and now things are
better a lot of the conversation became
about why the silence had been
maintained about the persistence of this
kind of repression so what that that
conversation eventually spilled over
into public events in Havana that were
restricted to members of the artisan
right of the Union and this produced a
very negative response from younger
people who couldn't be included who are
then galvanized to start to generate a
blog a world of blogs where they can
have a more open conversation about
things so bloggers start to meet weekly
okay and then in 2009 Yoani Sanchez who
is the most famous of all the Cuban
bloggers who's won all these awards and
is now has an endowed position at
Georgetown and is running a paper from
inside of Cuba begins what she calls her
blogger Academy which he holds in Havana
and also takes on the road to different
provincial cities in which she basically
teaches Cubans how to use WordPress or
how to use blogger we're not talking
about very sophisticated programming
here it's very very basic but we're
talking about a world in which only 10%
of the population has a landline at home
and you know there are
now I think a million and a half
cellphones in Cuba for a population of
10 to 11 million depending on whose
figures you follow so but she starts
this Academy and then another blogger
Lisa Bell Monica who is now a graduate
student at Princeton started a website
called that's all I got faith that was
basically how to write how do you do you
know given that you have very slow
dial-up service how do you how you deal
with the tech problems that arise from
this for people and at that point this
is also the cell phones are now easily
much more easily available at least
there are not as many leave there are no
legal restrictions on obtaining them so
the problem then becomes simply a
financial one this is what causes the
Cuban bog Wallis fear to explode on this
was unanticipated by the government and
so it took them a few months to figure
out that they had a problem on their
hands a political problem on their hands
and the response up to this point has
been to launch official blogs to
counteract the influence of the inter of
the independent blogs in outside the
country and at this point the number of
the ratio of government blogs to
independent plugs is two-to-one but the
readership of the independent blogs is
far surpasses those of the official
blogs okay so general problems about
connectivity well
first what's the political problem is
that the Internet is seen as a threat to
national security
by the Cuban government and that the
Internet is a pro-democracy imperative
for the US State Department so this is
what pits the two countries against each
other and it also what creates all the
money from USAID and other US government
initiatives to support the use of
technology some of you the digital
technology and get increasing Internet
access some of you may have read the
story about some sonio that broke on AP
last summer I'll get to that in a little
bit but that is up
kind of crystallizes what a lot of these
ongoing programs have been about so the
Cuban government's methods for
restricting act internet access they
don't it's not China they don't just say
you can't get you know Google is
inaccessible or you can't have a gmail
account it's done in a much more you
know in a less kind of categorical
manner so restricting bandwidth
censorship of sites that are critical of
the government prohibitive cost for most
Cubans and the criminalization of
certain kinds of communication right so
those are the main restriction methods
and then there's a problem of the sort
of debt access right that how few people
have landlines how few people have cell
phones and at this point internet access
is estimated at twenty five percent
penetration but that's it is very I
would dispute anybody's ability to come
up with an actually really accurate
figure because so much internet access
is done through the black market and
there's no way to measure how many
people steal service from hotels how
many people rent service from foreign
students or you know any of the other
means that how many I mean I suppose the
government could track how many people
buy foreign phone service packages to
access with data packages to access the
internet from their phones but it's very
difficult to measure these things most
internet is you know an in-country email
system and and to get an account
up until now you've had to basically be
the member of a union like the artists
and writers union or access through your
workspace for your workplace or if
you're a student access at the
University and so that gives the
government total control over how much
or how little you can do the company
that controls this is called a DEXA it's
the the the Cuban telephone company
monopoly and the cellphone part of it is
called its Guba sale and the new
internet packages that are available not
a package but the internet access that's
available to the population through the
cyber cafes is called nota right
some of you may have heard about the
case of Alan Gross which is another part
of the cyber war he was he's a guy who's
in been in prison in Cuba for the last
four years he's serving a 15 year
sentence he worked for a company in
Maryland that had a USAID contract and
he went made five trips to Cuba not
always masquerading as a tourist and he
was bringing in the kind of equipment
that frankly most people I know bring
into Cuba to give to their friends and
their families you know computers phones
and so on but he was caught with a
mobile phone some of you may know I
don't know what this is but a mobile
phone chip that makes satellite
transmission undetectable which
apparently you can only get from the
Pentagon or from the Department of
Defense and that was the thing that the
Cubans needed to be able to nail him at
you know for a kind of espionage so he
was arrested I think well he's he's been
in for four years he's been in prison I
think he was arrested in 2009 tried in
2010 if you could call what that what
you get there a trial and is serving the
sentence and there's been this ongoing
conversation about whether or not to
swap him with the four Cuban spies who
are still in prison in the United States
for having been lurking around Miami
looking for anti-castro activity and
this is still an open question okay so a
little bit of background on how things
got so heated is that that some of you
may recall that in 1994 there was a huge
rafter crisis in Cuba with 35,000 people
leaving on these makeshift boats and you
know many many many many as much as a
third to a half of the people who
attempt to leave probably died during
that time period and that is a constant
because this is continues to go on but
the crisis produced a shift in US policy
on Cuban immigration up to the
point anybody who left was going to be
taken as a refugee now you we have the
wet foot dry foot policy that you have
to have a foot on dry land right in
order to be given a refugee status and
otherwise you're returned so as part of
an attempt to try to save more lives
some groups in Miami will a group in
Miami that called itself brothers to the
rescue started flying planes over the
Florida Straits and to spot people and
then tell the Coast Guard to go and
collect them and they flew into Cuban
airspace in 1996 and the Cubans shot
down two planes and killed a bunch of
people and that was the event that
enabled Jesse Helms to get his
helms-burton Act passed in Congress to
tighten the US trade embargo and to
begin massive funding for pro-democracy
projects in Cuba that was this has been
debated the the bill had been debated
for several years and this is what got
it going so you know a lot of it is
about tightening tightening the
restrictions and being able to take
foreign come third country companies to
court for engaging in commerce with Cuba
but the most important thing for the
internet and information is this issue
of the funding for broadcasting to Cuba
so this includes the pro-democracy money
for groups on the ground and things like
tell MRT which is the big TV and radio
station that operates out of Miami
totally at the you know on the bill is
picked up by the US government okay it
is treated by many news outlets in the
United States as if it were a regular
news agency when it is in fact a
government operation that is now largely
manned by former employees of Cuban
television
okay so Cuba's response to this is to
introduce law 88 into the Cuban penal
code and which is a very long law but
the most important part part is that if
you can be found to be guilty of
spreading or reproducing materials
receive from the US government that
supports the objectives of undermining
cuban government you go to jail right
and you go to jail for a long time
because it's a considered these are
considered treasonous acts so the
seventy five people who were arrested in
2003 were arrested using law 88 okay and
here it says it's prison sentence up to
eight years that's what it says on the
law but most of the people in 2003 were
given 20 to 25-year sentences okay so
the more technical questions about
access service continues to be slow it
gets it's getting better I used to just
get up and walk away from hotel internet
centers because I paid eight dollars an
hour and just wait for one picture to
download it's getting better but it's
still very slow hotel access is now at
about six dollars so the price is going
down and you can buy these cards that
can reduce the price slightly if you buy
a large number of hours the new cyber
cafes for Cubans the raid is about four
dollars and fifty cents an hour which is
a lot
especially if you take into account what
the average salary is which is about
twenty dollars a month okay cell phones
have to be paid for in hard currency
it's about a dollar for each ms/ms if
you use MMS with pictures it's about 250
you know basically these prices are
prohibitive for most Cubans so if you
have a cell phone ther you're more than
likely just to use it for texting and
that's it and more recently now email
accounts are now you can have get email
on your phone if you have a phone but
still no access to the web okay
and this means that basically the
diaspora pays for the phones you know
there's two billion dollars in
remittances to Cuba every year there are
several I mean it's not all for cell
phone usage but it you know there are
many websites that are maintained both
in Miami and in Cuba that allow people
who want to charge to pay for cell
phones to do so from abroad and
most activists have a pay button
attached to their websites and their
blogs that allows you to donate money to
charge their phones or to charge their
phones directly it is a common request
that's made by activists are two people
in exile is to charge their phones so
that they can continue to send news
outside the country okay but everybody
does this knowing that everything is
monitored and if you work in let's say
you work for Grandma or you work for who
intuitive and if you work for one of the
an official news outlet you or any other
work place you must submit whatever
you're going to post for approval before
you post it so there's no there's no
independence if your work dissidents are
able to put a little bit of their stuff
into the bucket day or to make their own
bucket day and so to self or to COC sale
say it which is the Cuban version of
hard currency you know when you come in
from outside you have to change all your
dollars to a Cuban hard currency and the
government takes a cut off the top right
and so - so you'll see now is more or
less about two dollars but once upon a
time it was more like four dollars now
it's now it's down to about two so
that's not that doesn't seem like a lot
of money but again just have to keep in
mind how little money people make so but
but they're used widely and then there
are private game parlors that people set
up in a room in their houses and and
that's where the youth go to to play
okay what as far as if you are somebody
who needs to use the internet for your
work
okay whatever your work may be or if
you're somebody who you decided you're
going to be an independent journalist or
you know you just are not going to work
through state channels to do whatever
you do your options are you can rent
time on foreigners lines there are a lot
of foreign students and foreign
technicians in Cuba you less than there
used to be but they're around they can
have internet in their homes and they
will charge much less that
the hotel rate maybe half the hotel rate
so you might be paying three dollars an
hour instead of six dollars an hour so
there are people who I converse with
regularly who'd say I'll be able to chat
with you on FaceTime on Mondays between
three and four and that's their time
okay
another way is to steal Wi-Fi access
outside hotels especially around the
tourist areas there are a lot of really
sharp teenagers who know where they can
put laptops in an to fit the vicinity of
a hotel lobby and and take some of the
Wi-Fi from there and then they'll you
know if there's a an access code they'll
get in bribe employees to give them the
codes and then there's a the more
expensive way but the most effective way
for activists is to purchase foreign
phone data packages and SIM cards so
countries like Switzerland or Spain that
have a substantial amount of tourism to
Cuba will offer these data packages for
people traveling to the country we can't
do it because the American cell phones
don't work because of the the the trade
embargo right but so I know activists
who camp people outside the country who
financed by them the data package and
that allows them to have internet on a
phone right and that's that not
everybody that's that's expensive but
it's probably the best way to go
especially if you are worried about your
own safety because I don't know if you
heard about this activist Osvaldo pooja
who died in a mysterious car accident
2012 he had shut off his phone so as not
so so that the GPS wouldn't work but
that also gave the Cuban government 12
hours in which to have him die and have
no way to trace what happened right so
those are the wait now what do they call
hacking you know cuz I mean I don't I
have not been able to find anybody who
says oh yeah I hack into the Ministry of
Interior system and I go in the back
door and I know the code for them
hacking is really retooling of machines
right so they do there are a lot of
niche
creatives that bring you sale cellphones
into the country there are a lot of also
just traffickers of goods from the
states who make a living going back and
forth to function as a wholesale
supplier for people doing independent
businesses and they bring lots of used
cell phones and smart phones into the
country they have those have to be
altered to be able to work on the Kuban
phone system so you know I've gone into
backyards of people's houses where you
have six or seven guys there pulling
apart phones and getting them to work
and also pulling apart Playstations and
Nintendo's to get them to work without
having to use the whatever it is that
you need from here whatever software you
need so they also modify apps that are
for online to work offline to help
Cubans and every single bit of software
that's used in the government and
outside the government is cracked
software so you know people who know
enough about this stuff either about the
electronics or about computer
programming are making a very good
living right now adapting everything for
Cuban use okay there is also something
called rebel eco a website which is the
Cuban version of Craigslist and it's
totally illegal but it's thriving and
basically you can buy anything you know
any kind of Apple equipment any pro
computer program you need to edit and
you know the latest iPhone or a house or
a car or anything else on demo league by
answering ads on on veliko so those are
the that's the retooling so who are the
bloggers and the artists who use all
this media and what are they doing so
they're mostly blogging doing citizen
journalism political commentary there
are a lot of literary publications on
because Cuba's ability to publish has
diminished greatly since the withdrawal
of aid from the former Soviet Union and
and there's a lot of coverage of human
rights activist activities so that's a
the mostest cubanos is probably the most
best-known portal that was set up by
Yoani Sanchez in 2009 and hosts a number
of different blogs from people inside
Cuba and Havana Times also runs a lot of
commentary from a lot of different
bloggers on the island and is translated
into many languages they're linked up
with volunteers outside the country who
translate a lot of this into many
languages mostly into English I would
say and but like Yanni Sanchez's page
Generation Y is translated into 14
different languages daily by volunteers
which is really quite quite a feat
that's always subject to a lot of
speculation by the Cuban government of
you know this must be an indication that
she's a spy okay so here's johani the
best known blogger and with her blogger
Academy and I will say you know for
whatever criticisms there may be made of
her she has been quite generous in
sharing her knowledge and her tech
resources with others I mean she really
wants has wanted to create a movement
inside Cuba and not make the whole thing
be all about her although she's the
times you know hundred most important
pretty people of 2008 and you know gets
to meet with Joe Biden and so on and so
forth but she has she does run these
academies she does collect equipment and
flash drives for lots of people and she
has succeeded with her husband ray
nonetheless Givat who's over there
giving a talk at the academy in starting
the first online newspaper that comes
from Cuba which began this year okay
some of the other things that started up
as a you know in terms of how Cubans are
trying to help each other using blogging
is this nice I mean Monica is kind of
tech support online it's like their own
little internal conversation about you
know how do you get around the fact that
you have so little connectivity and then
the legal adviser buddy
diverse and who has offered her services
for free to dissidents to help them and
to get out of jail to deal with police
detentions and so on and so forth but
also to provide people with regular
updates in changes to Cuban laws so that
they know what limited rights they have
so how did they get started with all of
this because Cuba has lived for most of
the last 54 years in a total information
blackout right starts with blind
vlogging so send you know when people
just couldn't even get into a hotel to
access the Internet to put their posts
up they would blind blog so send SMS
text to friends outside the country and
have people outside maintain the site so
you have these telephone game style
chains for example of prisoners in jail
calling relatives when they get their
weekly phone call
having the relatives transcribed by hand
their reports from inside a prison that
then gets typed up by the family member
and taken to a blogger who converts it
into a 140 character SMS messages that
are sent outside the country to Spain or
Sweden or or New York and then posted on
a blog right that was the the old way of
doing things then Yoani began to teach
people about how to use email addresses
to send data directly to blog or Twitter
and YouTube but also she gave people the
I think it's an HTML code to be able to
do MMS from a Cuban phone because that
was key that was being able to do MMS
mints they could start to send pictures
and that really changed the nature of
journalism especially in the United
States journalistic coverage of Cuba
because they started cute American
outlets start to use data being sent
from Cuba by these independent
journalists and bloggers okay so the
Cuban
begins to fight back by flagging cuban
blogs to get them taken down or to flag
them on flag cuban bloggers who are
posting to Facebook so they got into the
game with this kind of hostile reaction
but then he somebody taught people how
to D to disable that function so that
they could get back on to Facebook or be
able to restore their blog to use so the
main challenge is that these bloggers
and independent journal journalists have
is that it's very difficult to build a
local base the Cuban government is very
much more concerned about controlling
their access to a local public than they
are about controlling their access to a
foreign public so just to give you an
example someone from this group estaba
lasats was in New York last week at NYU
and I was moderating a discussion and he
was talking about how they made the
group made a documentary about acts of
repudiation these kind of public
excoriation of dissidents and they were
able to distribute 500 DVDs in movie
theaters in Havana but they have over
300,000 hits on YouTube okay now most
Cubans cannot watch anything on YouTube
so most people watching outside are
outside Cuba right but that's the data
that I think is a a relatively accurate
measure of the difference in their
capacity to disseminate their message
there are the legal obstacles that are
created by the Cuban government I mean
you can go to prison so far since 2003 I
don't know of cases of people who are
going to prison for blogging right or
for being engaging in independent
journalism it seems that the Raul
Castro's Verge approach to this is to
try to D to destabilize them through
less harsh means to attack their
credibility to just took to describe
them as mercenaries
and so on and so forth so there have
been some you know very aggressive
skirmishes with police and detentions
that have lasted a few days but overall
the bloggers are not going to jail on ma
I'll mask the way that the independent
journalist did in 2003 there's this
total dependence on pro-democracy
funding from the US largely because
we're still in a cold war world when it
comes to Cuba and it's very the world
outside Cuba remains very polarized as
to you know whether whether this kind of
blogging is in fact you know a mercenary
activity or a destabilization project or
whether it's a project that is merits
you know being taken seriously and
treated as autonomous from the financial
source but this is there is this problem
that there's no gray area on this either
you take the money from the US or you
can't do it right and in some cases it's
unclear whether the activists are even
aware of the original source of the
money because these this money is
funneled through Allied states through
Poland through the Czech Republic
through Sweden and also it also comes
through foundations in the u.s. who
don't necessarily make its so known you
know what it is
what money they're what they depend on
there's a okay there's an another
dimension to this though is it's not
necessarily it's not all about blogging
and activism it's also about giving
unofficial cultures unofficially
recognized cultures a chance to flourish
and to have a way of disseminating their
information and building audiences both
inside and outside the country and in
that sense all of this kind of
connectivity through telephones and
through embassies and these indirect
means has really helped to for example
the the publication of this magazine bol
says that publishes all sorts of
literature poetry and commentary by
writers who don't come through the
official channels so they haven't
graduated from the University of Havana
with a degree in follow Jake um from the
hard science that the editor was a I
think a biologist in Cuba before he
became a fiction writer so but this
gives an alternative means of publishing
literature that's been it's been very
important for this it's also been very
important for artists who don't have
official recognition from the artists
and writers union because up until very
recently if you didn't have that
membership you could first of all be
denied the right to travel because you
didn't have professional status as an
artist and beyond that you could have
any public event of yours shut down
because it wasn't being channeled
through official institutions so being
able to have an ongoing online video
diary has served as a kind of protective
shield but also as a kind of online
gallery to exhibit and so these guys you
know they even document their whole sort
of final acquisition of visas to travel
in 2013 and this is after their having
been having been working as artists for
17 years without any official
recognition there's also a lot of
independent film production going on
because of this media that is now
distributed via online sources and a lot
of it deals with subjects that cannot be
treated by the Kuban within the
community television system or the
official Cuban film industry in web
valeriano who also works free kite but
he makes the films that he wants to make
on the side this piece won't that rule
is about the visit of two security
agents to the house of an intellectual
it's not something that you're going to
ever see in a Cuban film right this
documentary by de carvalho about rappers
is all about the politics of rap and
Cuba which is maintains a very kind of
oppositional position visa be the
government I mean again would not you
would not find material like this on TV
and rappers
are almost entirely dependent rappers
with political rap are almost entirely
dependent on this kind of independent
distribution probably the most famous
case of a musician whose career is
entirely dependent on the internet is
this punk rocker or Gorky Aguila who's
been arrested twice served four years in
prison between 2003 and 2007 I believe
on trumped-up drug charges and is this
kind of you know the most famous awful
TV of the Cuban music scene comes to the
United States very often to perform for
audiences of up to 10,000 or 15,000 in
Miami distributes his music via internet
and is totally banned inside the country
but it's very notorious been the subject
of BBC documentaries and so on and so
forth and uses the video video diary
motif or method as well to protect to
shield himself from more police
harassment so the second time he was
arrested he actually didn't have to
serve a prison sentence and I do think
that it's because of the media attention
outside the country so the cyber battles
I mentioned open SEO marathon and
there's le s ed confessing to Yoani and
here talking to questioning the
president of the National Assembly in
public in 2008 these are things that
nobody outside would have ever heard
about before were it not for this kind
of emergent blogosphere and and then you
get the kind of parodying of official
media so you have good ad ma the
official newspaper of the Communist
Party and wama the parody of the
newspaper being produced outside of the
country and you know for the first time
the Cuban government finds itself unable
to maintain a hegemonic control over the
image of what's going on inside and then
you have these blog dailies about Cuba
that are couture see me do is Yanni's
which is based in Havana Cuba encuentro
is based in Spain like diario de Cuba
Anette is in miami and but there they
they base themselves there but they're
the contributors are largely from the
island right and Gotha fuerte is also
based in miami and these are all now you
know their blogs i mean they're not
official newspapers by any stretch of
the imagination but they represent what
would be an opposition press right and
they're quoted by wire services and CNN
in spanish and fox latino and so on and
so forth the direct line to washington
is really clear because all of the
reports from these bloggers end up in
basically entering the american medias
through fear through these channels and
and then but you know when they talk
publicly everybody who comes from the
island stresses the importance of the
exile communities support and it is
relevant it is significant I mean
there's seventeen million dollars in
USAID money something like 80% of that
stays inside the United States there's
two billion dollars of Cuban remittance
money every year it's as far more you
know financial weight of the remittances
is far bigger than the USAID but so some
of the means that that these exile
community support groups from the means
of support is recharging cell phones
this group of roots of hope which
actually started at Harvard with Cuban
students at Harvard several years ago
they do a lot of technology donation so
they gather used cell phones buy flash
drives and bring them they or they help
to organize dissident tours in the US
they've organized kind of how do how do
you call it copycat protests in Miami
that mimic activists events inside Cuba
and so on
young luma is the Cuban version of
Kickstarter that was started to support
independent cultural projects but it got
stopped in 2013 by the Treasury
Department because of the trade embargo
restrictions so it's in hiatus now yes
we have to stop it about 25 minutes left
so it really is a question of how much
okay well I'm almost done I'm almost
done
so these are the Cuban money project is
a run by Tracy Eaton that tries to
analyze the financial part of this like
where the money's going the USAID money
and that's also on hiatus since 2013
this is the the Twitter controversy the
Tsun Tsun ale that you know depending on
whose version of it it's either a
destabilization program or it's helping
the Cubans or it's just totally
ineffective and then just at the end
these are these some example of some of
the affluent official blogs they don't
have to pay so that's there they don't
have to pay to access the internet they
can get on from work without any control
on that their goal is to foment debate
but their content is restricted they're
supposed to adopt the persona of the
reformer within the system so you have
like the gay official blogger right the
young student blogger and they but they
have learned how to move information
into news threads to challenge the
independent bloggers and then there are
some that just devote themselves
exclusively to counter-attacking
counter-attack to going after the
dissidents so I think I just want to
give a couple of examples of activism
that were has worked in Cuba using the
internet there's this group called the
red upside but audiokinetic oh and a lot
of their work is ecologically oriented
they're not so much interested in
publishing in The Huffington Post
they're interested in kind of social
practice community-based activism about
getting people in Cuba to understand
what the threats ecological threats are
because it is an extremely kind of
ability to biosphere at this point and
the most successful I would say
international activist campaign came
from 2010 around the death of this
political prisoner Orlando Cepeda my
aware activists inside and outside Cuba
mobilized together to combine Street
action and online action to pressure the
Cuban government to release the other
political prisoners that were still in
prison in 2010 from the ones who were
arrested in 2003 and so this included
copycat marches in 36 different cities
around the world all sorts of petitions
and the hunger strike by the animal
fighting yes that lasted 135 days yes
there was not his first and it produced
the release of the last 50 political
prisoners right now this is the other
campaign that's going on which is about
getting the Cuba to sign agreements on
Human Rights with the United Nations so
sorry that went on for so long but as
you see it's kind of complicated so I'll
stop here so that we have some time for
questions and I see we already have
questions queuing up and I think what
you're going to find is there are some
people here who know Cuba reasonably
well there's a lot of people here who
know parallel media environments where
there are similarities and differences
and as someone who sort of studied
online censorship for the last ten years
it's really interesting for me to sort
of think about what sort of the
different phases we've seen in online
censorship so there have been sort of
three books written by a group of people
who study censorship the first was
access denied and this was sort of the
first version either you you weren't
connected to the internet right or you
censored very heavily and then there was
access controlled and this was really a
theory of did you turn off access at
particular times did you shut
connectivity before an election where
there's certain sites that would go off
on others would be open and then the
most recent paradigm in this has been
sort of access contested and this is
where stuff gets really interesting this
is where you have counter bloggers
coming online this is where you have
services run either with government
cooperation or with very strong
government oversight often with blocking
other services out of there and what
we've seen through most of the world is
this sort of gradual move from sort of
where Cuba was sorry you're not gonna
have access to this to look of course
you're gonna have to have access to this
but it's going to be a very complicated
space mm-hmm and part of what's been so
tricky about this is the debate over how
one deals with speaking in this space
looking for creative speech looking for
a little bit strange looking for
assisted speech often hasn't caught up
so you still have people you know trying
to basically parachute radios into Cuba
right
despite sort of not realizing that you
know we're a couple of generations
beyond that so my guess is that some of
the reactions we're gonna get from
friends around the table are sort of
looking at some sort of parallels in
other situations but I think maybe just
anticipating what Dahlia wants the size
[Music]
and I guess it's interesting to see that
there was some of while interesting
observations that came out of the air
clubs fears the fact that a lot of
people don't blog anymore especially
political blogs where it's like there is
no point
partially I guess is because there's a
shift to other forms of social media
Twitter and Facebook and and another
friend of this sort of access as access
door it's like you have people who are
counteract like that pro-government
forces or other forces that are contract
active that conversation and I'm just
curious to hear of what you think and
there are a lot of interesting offices
more interesting links within the cubing
office fear the fact that I'd be curious
to hear what you think well I think that
one of the things that I noticed is that
very very few bloggers in Cuba have a
sense of the top blog time of online
time of this that you know in the States
everything moves so fast
bloggers blog every day right or more
than once a day and you know Cubans are
not used to that kind of speed in
anything I mean it takes four hours to
get to work so why you know when how are
you gonna do a blog every day there's
also much less of a sense of the the the
the tactical use of brevity you know
that a lot of blogs are very long the
the post very church so it makes it
difficult for an outsider to get through
them and to figure out what's going on
in that sense Yoani Sanchez has been
very successful because she understood
the 140 characters as a kind of
challenge right but she produced some
also blogs in brief blogs with very
vivid vivid imagery in a very common
person's language that made them very
easy to translate and very easy to
understand outside of the human context
so she's been very successful I think
other bloggers have been less successful
at understanding the pace and the kind
of ecology of blogging outside the
country nonetheless the demand for
information from inside is so great you
know that they're gonna I mean they're
you know they're an to see entities out
the outside of the country that's going
to draw that information out of bloggers
whether they want to give it or not I
mean that's the the sense that I get is
that there's a tremendous demand for
this information and there are there's a
machinery in the United States for
absorbing it so you know that that is
going to produce more blogs even if it
doesn't happen at
the speed that we're accustomed to here
just said there is there are consumers
outside I think that speed up submission
is yes right on because I mean this has
been a really fascinating space and
blogging sort of comes to the fore and
maybe 12 years ago and in a lot of the
places we study it died three or four
years ago and it really died as Twitter
instead of Facebook took over and
basically for people who weren't writing
essays but we're doing the observational
and sort of you know what we kind of
joke of is like the dopamine blogging
they're just looking for someone to sort
of receive the information that's moved
into this much lighter weight media oh
and in the u.s. at least what happened
was the bloggers have become mainstream
journalists in a very funny way you know
I still blog but when I actually want an
audience I write for the Atlantic all
right when you're in a place where
there's still so much to report and
where you don't have the possibility of
that sort of dopamine delivery system of
I put it up in my ten friends like that
it seems to me quite possible that it
may survive quite a while because it's
the right technology for the moment in
terms of Internet penetration and
possibly in terms of what the larger but
also there are there are some among them
who are becoming huffington post's
contributors on a regular basis or sam
sonia way or what so so there I mean
it's not as fast a process but it's it's
there so here's an interesting question
I'm gonna go over to chenglong yes but
one other dynamic in this that I think
most of us aren't used to thinking about
is that the Cuban diaspora in the u.s.
in particular in huge powerful is
certainly influential within US politics
clearly sort of involved in some of
these dialogues not every blogosphere
has that same sort of dynamic while
there's an enormous Chinese diaspora
there's far more people on Chinese
social media in China and that has a lot
to do with how Chinese social media
dialog it's a question I know your talk
is focused on the digital and it seems
that in the digital space there is so
little breathing room for voices of
opposition to be heard but at the same
time there is such a great demand for
information right so I'm wondering what
about the other media the the other
mediums underground it's actually more
easy to be monitored in Cuba here's the
this yeah it's almost impossible to get
a photocopy done in Havana it's almost
impossible to print anything the enemy
propaganda laws that are part of the
Cuban penal code criminalize
publications that are not officially
sanctioned but this is the problem okay
so the people who were just to give you
a sense the people who were arrested in
2003 they were trying to circulate print
media it was really easy to come down on
them using the enemy propaganda laws
okay
they were also many of them were
independent librarians so people who
would collect samus dot the even
equivalent of some estat
books on human rights or just books on
by exiled writers or writers that were
banned in the country and keep
collections to be able to use his
references and also to keep collections
of the you know underground printing and
you know that's physical media that's
really easy to locate and say here it is
this is you know this is banned you have
it you you're arrested it isn't it isn't
it's actually harder for them to deal
with the flashdrive culture right now
and that's why the government's response
to the flashdrive bucket day has been to
sort of go into a whole kind of moral
you know Krita scrit critique and saying
that this is it has a degenerative
effect on the society as a whole to have
all this forbidden media circulating
through through the flash drive so I
mean this is the thing is that
I've been surprised so far that there
has been no addition to the Penal Code
to criminalize the digital media because
there they're not there that has not
happened yet and you know some people
say it's because the leadership is so
old they're just totally out of touch
with what young people are doing but
it's to me it's very surprising
considering how effective the laws
around em and enemy propaganda have been
in preventing people from publishing
inside so it's always nice for me when
something that I wrote you know ten
years ago has a certain amount of
relevance but I wrote a paper some years
ago called the KitKat theory oh that
argued that the most powerful media in
closed societies was the popular media
so going in and trying to set up your
special here's the Twitter that's gonna
undermine the Cuban government you know
that that [ __ ] never works
it's too dangerous to play with it's
only reaching a small group of people
the stuff that's actually powerful is
the quotidian media it's what everybody
is using and it's really hard to ban
because everybody uses that and so for
instance for the Arab Spring what was
really powerful was video particularly
over Facebook everybody was on Facebook
you weren't gonna ban Facebook in
Tunisia because you would have had
another rebellion on your hands but that
turned out to be a way to get video out
and that video once it ended up on al
Jazeera turned out to be very powerful
in Cuba it's probably the pot kept it
home and it's probably the fact that you
know whether it's movies whether it's
music whether or not you're slipping the
news and they're activists moving in
there
in fact as long as it's got a certain
amount of pervasiveness that's going to
become a powerful channel for somebody
whether it's a channel internally for
someone to get dissident media out
whether it's a channel for someone
external I think you're right that
probably the greatest threat to this is
in some ways having that become too
politicized and having that probably
become illegalized to really crack
at the same time but it is interesting
to sort of see the ways in which local
media sort of rising up to meet those
needs
the bloggers who are in Cuba posting
things at the very very beginning there
were some bloggers who didn't use
pseudonyms and as a matter of fact
there's a woman named Miriam celaya who
is one of the better-known bloggers now
who can who came out at one point is
like okay I've made a decision I'm going
to do this using my name so as far as I
know at this point in time people who
are blogging are using their names but
you know if you you go you once you
enter this world of being a dissident
there you basically move into a kind of
grey zone where you experience a kind of
social death in Cuba you you can't work
you can't get a job anywhere anymore you
know you will probably be shunned by
people who will fear for their
livelihoods right so they end up in
these very kind of small enclosed
subcultures where they don't have a lot
of communication with others they are
also subject all the time to being
accused of being mercenaries because
they're they get paid by the nation
seventy five dollars or you know
whatever I mean some bloggers money gets
paid a lot more now but she's really an
exception right I mean the the amount of
screaming about how they're all hired
hands of the CIA I find really laughable
because most of the money from the
government stays in the United States to
the beltway consultants and the
Foundation's that are you know managing
all of this stuff so they're not making
a lot but they might make something or
they might get a fax machine or a
computer or a cell phone given to them
to be able to do stuff they do use
Twitter the bloggers use to at Twitter
basically at this point everything is
all linked they have they do the you
know I post and then it goes to Twitter
and Facebook and I'm done right and
that's economically more viable for them
than just having one or the other and
they
are some of the more savvy ones who know
to use Twitter to protect themselves
when they're in a protest if they're
about to be arrested they have a Twitter
message ready to go and then immediately
it goes to that I my fee and then it
goes from there to Fox News and to CNN
and espanol and the next day they're
released from the police station so let
me ask maybe a pointed question of us
which is you've given I I think a really
nuanced but also sort of critical view
of the US and all of this which is to
say there's a huge amount of US money
trying to come into Cuba at best you
could argue that it's trying to carve
out a digital public sphere that is
going to make independent journalism
artistic creativity all of these things
happen at worst you could argue that
it's an enormous pile of money mostly
going to defense contractors Beltway
bandits USA contractors who may be doing
more harm than good and who may be
endangering everyone they touch you've
got the ear of John Kerry you've got
five minutes to make a case for what the
US does through the State Department in
Cuba what do you tell Secretary Kerry on
this well first of all that what Alan
Gross did was very dangerous and that
Tsun Tsun AO is a waste of time the
Cubans are more of more adept at
figuring out how to use those systems to
their advantage that is so you know I
don't think that trying to send you know
Central American young adults in there
as was the sort of the extension of
since oh no it's going to be very
effective it's more effective when
Cubans organize themselves right on the
other hand I would be much happier with
a more a more diverse source sources of
funding in other words if there were
other options so that it wasn't so
polarized that would like that I think
that would be more comforting and I
think also that it's really important
for the Cubans who are inside to not be
so
unquestioning in their acceptance of
alliances with organizations in Florida
in particular that are essentially
rehabilitating themselves through this
partnership because these were the same
organizations that were sponsoring
violent opposition up until the 1980s
and so but there's no there's no way to
have a conversation about that nobody
wants to you know and these are like I
don't think I'm the only person in the
world who's aware of this stuff and I
don't I also think it's important on the
left not to call what these Cubans are
doing mercenary activities because I
don't think that the desire to have
independent journalism in Cuba or the
desire to have independent culture or
temporary autonomous zones where you can
organize your own activities is
something that was invented by the
United States I think that's something
that really is a grassroots demand and
desire and that and to to equate that
with a kind of you know CIA top-down
operation is wrong it's an incredibly
challenging somewhat unfair question and
that was let's get a couple more
questions in
and they're all suffering so how do you
approach the credibility of these ideas
dissidents and cultural workers in the
sense in the way that they're isolated
put their writing born here they're
performing for if they're not received I
would venture having the Arab Spring
with the kind of local not everybody
okay not everybody in Cuba has that much
to lose at this point I mean the the era
in which the government controlled
everything information you know console
it'll bit of consumerism that existed
the educational system is over I mean
essentially with the withdrawal of
support from the former Soviet Union the
economy went into a tailspin and that
has forced Cuba to take on a more
friendly relationship with the exile
community and also to develop different
kinds of alliances but also to withdraw
the force of the public sector from
every aspect of life I mean the
government can't pay for everybody's
food anymore they can't provide enough
housing the educational system is in
shambles if you want to go to a hospital
your relatives have to send you the
anesthesia to have an operation so you
know in that kind of situation and also
where information and media is
constantly coming in from outside thus
the the the kind of totalizing hold that
the government had is no longer there so
for some people they don't really care
that much as long then nobody wants to
go to jail but it's not like it's not
things aren't the ideologically it's not
as airtight as things were let's say up
until 1990 okay so in that sense yeah
there are people who don't want to get
involved because they don't want to be
in trouble but you don't get the same
kind of public shunning as you might
have another period of time you just
you have people just not want to hang
out with you right now not want to be at
your meetings and things like that um
you know in terms of credibility I have
to say I think that there are some
activists like the ladies in white who
were the female relatives of the
political prisoners who yes they did
receive training from the US interest
section but they had a real political
cause and I think that they have a real
following I think in great sympathy both
inside and outside the country in that
sense I think it has been a very
effective movement and that it would be
inaccurate to characterize them as tools
of the the US government and they got
they got the prisoners out so that was a
that's been that's been good I think
some of the others are less known to the
public but also that their goals and
their interests are less aligned with
what the majority population is
concerned with right now people are
concerned with getting money and getting
out that's it all right so if you're
worried about the political transition
and who's gonna be in the next
government and you know what what's
gonna happen when Miami Cubans come in
and start pouring money into the economy
I mean for most people who are living
there those are not immediate concerns
so for me like as some an observer
outside who is concerned about both the
you know people's daily lives and the
ability of artists to create an
independent culture and what does it
really mean for the u.s. which you know
embraces authoritarian capitalism all
over the world
to be trying to tell dissidents to argue
for free speech you know I I worry about
it but I have the luxury of being able
to do that from here I don't know if
that's everybody else is concerned about
Bush's us do in this situation here is
there are apparently to pass the one had
it lifted Pargo
and leather economy boom and like people
organize by themselves and maybe hope
they will move into the next phase of
control
they will catch something else the
second path is to squeeze the Cubans and
like it explode like like what you said
they have no choice they have nothing to
lose so if you are an adviser of the
Obama government
well I the thing is I don't think that
you can just lift the embargo it's it's
what else is good what else are you
gonna do what how I think the concern to
the United States right now as far as I
understand it is number one they think
Cuba sends sell secrets to Syria and
Iran that's the kind of political
problem with Cuba right now that's
number one and they also are worried
about a migration another mass migration
of Cubans to the United States
twenty-two thousand humans have arrived
in the US illegally in the last 11
months that's almost as many as during
the rafter crisis so they're not all
going on rafts now they're taking
flights to Ecuador and walking with with
smugglers all the way through Central
America through Mexico into the United
States but that's a lot of people and
the southern Florida economy can't
absorb them okay so those are like real
concerns in Washington other problem is
how many electoral votes Florida has and
the political force of the Cuban and
American machine right and what can what
can the u.s. do to Cuba that's not going
to upset the political stability of
either the Republicans or the Democrats
in the state of Florida okay so and you
know the the Miami Cuban community is
divided on what whether or not to lift
the embargo there are many who say yes
and there are others who say no the ones
who say don't lift it are the
Republicans who are probably identified
with the older generation right the
younger people are less interested in
the embargo and but I just think that if
there is going to be a lifting of the
embargo and there's also got to be a
change in immigration policy and some
sort of you know 21st century century
version of
martial plan for the rebuilding of a
country that is devastated
economically not just politically it
looks like it's been bombed over and
over again in a war and so you can't
just then let you know anybody come into
the country and do whatever because
they'll turn it into the Bahamas into
just like a bunch of hotels and that's
not a solution that's going to produce
more migration right anywhere other than
other than there which is the situation
with most of the Caribbean so I you know
I see it as very complicated and where
the whole kind of human rights civil
rights thing fits in all of this too
leaves me with a lot of questions
because I don't see I see those issues
right now as a way to harass the current
Cuban government but I'm not so sure
what the USS commitment is to those
things post-transition so incredibly
helpful last question amazing
presentation thank you so thank you
[Applause]